- Trump, the name is
synonymous with quality,
luxury, being better
than losers, and class.
Its been on golf courses,
casinos, and beautiful meat.
Now, I'm lending my name
to the failing game show,
At Midnight, and they need
it, they need it tremendously.
I've bought and paid for
every episode this week,
just like I bought and paid
for my beautiful wife, Melania.
And soft little nougat
chinchilla Chrissy Hardwick
is going to play the
games I want to play.
It's to be huge,
stupendous, the bestest.
Okay, you losers, here's
more than you deserve.
Trump Presents At Midnight.
(audience cheering)
- And now it's time for
tonight's #HashtagWars.
(audience cheering)
Tonight's sponsor, Donald Trump,
has a very interesting grasp
on the English language.
If he wasn't
sponsoring the show,
I'd say that he
rambles like a toddler
on bath salts, but
he is, so I can't.
So in order to celebrate
2016's most innovative orator,
tonight's hashtag
is #TrumpAQuote.
#TrumpAQuote is
tonight's hashtag.
(audience cheering)
- Why are you clapping?
I don't know why
you're inviting him.
- Okay.
Okay, stop talking,
wee-willy-Seacrest.
I paid for this episode, and I'm
gonna play in this
segment, because no one
is better at quoting me than me.
(audience laughing)
I am tremendous, I'm
incredible at it.
I'm incredible Chip.
Also, all my answers are worth
eight times the points
of everyone else.
(audience laughing)
You got it?
You got it Chuck?
- I don't,
I feel dirty.
(audience laughing)
- You should have your
daughter bathe you at night.
(audience laughing)
- I don't really,
a, have a daughter.
Tonight's (laughing).
(audience laughing)
Katie, you alright?
(laughing)
Alright, tonight's
hashtag is #TrumpAQuote.
Examples might be "All
the world's a stage
"and all the men and
women are merely losers."
I'm gonna put 60
seconds on the clock.
Begin.
(bell dinging)
Doug Benson.
- I see debt people.
- Alright, points.
(audience laughing)
(bell dinging)
Katie Sackhoff.
- Life is like a
box of chocolates
that's fun to steal
from poor people.
- [Chris] Alright points.
(bell dinging)
Natash--
- Excuse me, excuse me.
Forget it Jake, China town.
It's China town.
- Alright, yeah, I've--
- A million points.
- Fine, fine, fine.
Natasha.
- You can't judge a book
by its ghost writer.
- Alright, points.
(bell dings)
(audience cheering)
Very good.
Doug Benson.
- [Trump Impersonator]
Excuse me Chris, excuse me--
- It was Doug's turn.
- Excuse me.
- Ask not what you can
do for your country,
ask how you can (bleep)
my daughter out.
- Alright, ugh.
(audience laughing and groaning)
I
cannot give you points for that
and ever sleep soundly again.
Doug Benson.
- We're gonna need
a bigger vote.
- [Chris] Alright points.
(bell dings)
Very good.
(audience laughing)
Katie Sackhoff.
- One small step for man,
and two small hands for me.
- Alright points.
(bell dings)
(audience cheering)
- Excuse me, excuse me--
- Doug buzzed in.
- Excuse me.
- What?
- Call me Ishmael, but that
does sound like a Muslim name,
so maybe we should take
me out of the country.
- Alright, (laughing)
Jesus Christ!
(audience laughing)
- I'm the devil, I'm the devil.
- I do not feel good
about this at all.
Ugh, Doug Benson.
- Luke, people are saying
I'm your father, I don't know
if it's true but that's what
people have been saying.
- Alright points (laughs).
(bell dings)
Natasha Lyonne.
- Mr. Gorbachev, keep
the wall in tact.
- [Chris] Alright points.
(audience laughing)
(bell dings)
Doug Benson.
- Phone home, uh, no,
you're an illegal alien,
your fingers are longer
than mine, you gotta go.
- [Chris] Alright points.
(audience laughing)
- Excuse me, excuse
me, excuse me--
- What?
- Excuse me, get
him out of here!
- What?
- Excuse me.
- Okay.
- Am I my brother's keeper?
Of course I am, he's locked up
in GTMO with everybody else.
- Alright, um.
(audience laughing)
(bell dings)
Yes, points for that.
Natasha.
- I love the smell of
spray tan in the morning,
it smells like victory.
- Alright points.
(audience laughing)
Is that what you said?
I wanna touch your
face, it's so...
- [Katie] I like that.
- It's made out of
stress ball material.
(audience laughing)
- Well, that brings us to
the end of #HashtagWars.
You can send us
your #TrumpAQuote
and tag those @midnight
to keep the game going.
- The country's
a nightmare, huh?
(laughing)
- I won, she's got
pneumonia, she has polio,
I don't know what
this guy's problem is.
I'm winning, I'm winning.
Everyone else is sick,
everyone else is sick.
- I'm really sorry,
we don't know
when he's gonna turn
up for the rest of
the week so please
just bear with us,
we're trying to keep
the lights on here.
We'll be right back
with more At Midnight.
(audience cheering)
- [Narrator] Our
Tweet of the Day
from our last #HashtagWar was
sent to us by @realDonald...
Really?
Oh Jesus.